i'm kat timf i'm bill hemmer i'm harris
faulkner and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday august 24th 2022 i'm chris
foster it's already happening in some
states and now there's a new bipartisan
push in congress to help college
athletes get paid we want to make it
simplified and we want to make it easier
for coaches and the players to
understand what they can do and can do
and so they can get back to a normal
life where it's not an advantage for any
team please be with alabama senator and
former college football coach tommy
tuberville
i'm lisa brady the white house rejects
recession talk but employers are feeling
a chill we've been in a really strong
labor market for a long time the concern
though shows that companies are bracing
for potential downturn already prepping
their businesses and maybe already
making cuts we've seen a ton this summer
and i'm marty mccary i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
since california passed its fare to play
act in 2019 28 other states have now
passed laws allowing college athletes to
make money for marketing their name
image and likeness referred to as nil
athletes like nebraska cornhuskers
freshman wide receiver dakotas crawford
with a name like that is in a commercial
for an hvac company in omaha when your
ac isn't the coldest you call sos
heating and cooling their ticks don't
make commissions so they give you an
honest opinion fair pricing and longer
warranties than a competition guaranteed
take it from the codes
[Music]
the hooters restaurant chain sponsoring
51 offensive linemen from different
teams members of the texas tech women's
basketball team have 25 000 deals with a
branding company the ncaa ended its ban
on players profiting from their name
image and likeness in june 2021 seeing
the legal writing on the wall after a
supreme court decision that other rules
restricting education-related benefits
were illegal so amateur athletes are now
covered by state law instead of ncaa
rules alabama senate republican tommy
tuberville is working on federal
legislation to cover every college
athlete in america well we're just
trying to work together try to get
something done for this name image and
likeness in college sports he was a
division one college football coach for
21 seasons with ole miss auburn texas
tech and cincinnati he was elected to
the senate in 2020 now working with west
virginia democrat joe manchin on this
nil legislation he and i have worked
together on a few other things and he
also was a college football player and
so knows a little bit about what these
young athletes and coaches go through so
you know working working together with
our staffs and some other people
we're talking with athletic directors
commissioners former players present
players coaches we're just trying to get
some kind of sense of reality back into
college sports and i think this is you
know you take two people that's been
involved in sports that have
love for the sport and so
hopefully we can get something done but
i tell you there's a there's a lot of
moving parts to this issue yeah there
sure is um
i mean i guess one of the differences
here with
compared to some of the other bills is
that you're actually you know some of
the people involved here you're close
with them and you're trying to get them
involved and use them to craft the bill
right when you're talking to athletic
directors and student athlete groups to
get to get feedback what are you hearing
back yeah there's a lot of interest but
there's also a lot of different ideas of
how to get something done and you know
what we didn't want to get involved this
in terms of being the federal government
problem is they've gone now a year maybe
a year and a half and it's getting worse
you know you can't run a business you
can't run anything
that a lot of people are involved in
without rules and regulations we're not
in this joe manchin are not in this to
stop the money from players getting
money i was a coach for 40 years and
understood and always cool for the
players making more and more money
because it's a tough job and it's too
tough job going to school and playing
athletics it doesn't give you time to
really realize a real life it takes too
much of your time so that being said
we're not getting in the money part what
we want to do is bring together rules
and regulations of what coaches and
players can do when they can do it along
with the teams
and right now you've got 50 different
states across america
all of them have college sports all of
them are going by different rules and
regulations you can't have a
true
business model unless everybody goes by
the same rules and regulations because
if you have differences
then you're going to have people that
have a
advantage over the other so that's what
we're trying we're trying to put some
rules and regulations for the players
and coaches where they can understand
what they can do and can't do in their
particular sport yeah i mean by unless
like unless i miscounted 29 states have
at least passed
nil laws some of them haven't been
enacted yet
but so that leaves 22 without them and
like you said it's it's
part of the the question here as is
always with big college athletics versus
small college athletics is um is the
competitive advantage is this going to
make it even more of a reason for top
recruits to go to bigger and bigger
schools
yeah and you're exactly right and then
you've got the different sports
and here's the problem we're going to
have with this a lot of this money that
are going to go to a lot of these
players which again i'm fine with
but at the end of the day the money that
goes a lot of these players
are going to take away from a lot of the
lesser sports they might not be lesser
but they have less athletes you have
women's sports olympic sports
and
universities are going to lose all this
money that's going to these players
and you're going to have universities
that are going to start dropping these
sports and so we want to look out for
everybody this is not just for football
or for basketball this is for everybody
and you said 29 states had enacted laws
they have enacted laws but the problem
is a lot of these laws are different in
each state so
the only way we're going to be able to
get this done without working with the
ncaa which they pretty much wash your
hands of this because they have lawsuits
right and left well if the federal
government makes out a few not a lot we
don't want to put a serious catalog of
rules and regulations we want to just
get an outline of things that every
school can do every coach can do
every player that can expect
where at the end of the day everybody is
on the same page but right now as you
said 29 states of enacted laws but some
of those states
allow you to offer money to players that
are still in high school and some do not
allow you to do that and so we're just
trying to make it to where everybody's
the same
where everybody has the same
advantage or disadvantage when you go
into recruiting yeah i mean i know
you're you know again you're a small
government guy i so are you trying to is
your goal here just come up with
guidelines and recommendations and just
kind of hope everybody latches on to it
or is there a way to actually legislate
this
well i think we can legislate it to a
certain point
end of the day you can't limit the
amount of money anybody's getting you
know that's that's not what this is
about this is about giving the
opportunity when a coach goes out
what they can tell a player but they
can't tell a player the time limits when
that can happen right now you have
coaches that are going out and
recruiting 9th and 10th graders
and money's involved i don't think
that's right i think that there's a lot
taken away from that when you get down
in that level of recruiting i think
we've got to put some
constraints on time
and the level of contacts that you can
make in terms of of a young man because
when i was in college uh coaching which
was five six years ago then you know the
that young man or young woman that was
being recruited
you weren't you were limited to the
amount the younger they were because you
want them to have a a high school life
you don't want it to turn into be a
pre-brawl for college coaches coming and
visiting with you so we want to make it
easier for the players easier for the
recruits simplified for the conferences
everybody be on the same page and let
the coaches know hey this is what you
can do this is what you can't do and
this one you can do it and then get back
to some kind of normalcy and and all of
the sports in college yeah i mean joe
manchin's also buddies with alabama
coach nick saban i'm not sure if you if
you're still buddies with them uh
they're both from west virginia and
saban says look things are out of
control um with these deals notre dame's
a.d says he thinks the ncaa screwed up
here by by by getting out of it yeah
they probably have i can understand
where they're coming from uh they're
supposed to be the leader in this
situation again i didn't want to because
i loved college sports i think it does
a tremendous amount for our youth and
our country uh bill's leaders uh but the
ncaa is basically after the year's
nightballs when it when it comes to
litigation so
i think after watching this for the last
year and a half or two years from my
perspective if we can help now there
might not be anything we can do chris
after the end of the day we get all
these uh again i sent a letter out to
all almost everybody involved in terms
of commissioners ads coaches
uh some players people involved in in
sports
and we're getting recommendations every
day from a lot of these people uh that
we sent this letter to of asking give us
your best thoughts of how we can bring
you this senator tubbrill and senator
manchin we can't do this alone we've got
to have some expertise from the from out
in the field of what these people have
seen over the last year and a half two
years but hopefully at the end of the
day we might be able to come up with
something that everybody can agree with
it's going to be hard to do that i
understand it but we want to make it
simplified and we want to make it easier
for coaches and the players to
understand what they can do and can do
and so they can get back to a normal
life where it's a it's not an advantage
for any team everybody has the same
advantage and you can go after it and
and know what to expect uh every day of
the calendar
i'm wondering if this i and i haven't
dug into these state laws state by state
but i'm wondering if this is a backdoor
way
for boosters for rich boosters to just
throw money at kids with no restrictions
okay i i love florida state
i have a you know i have a lot of money
i'm gonna pay you a million bucks to
come play here for the rights to your
name image and likeness even though i'm
not going to do anything with it
well my understanding is that's
happening as we speak and that's reason
we need to get control of this again i
don't
that money is out there and it's going
to be out there and there's there's been
as i
talked and saw a comment from lane
kiffin who's the head coach at the
university of mississippi said they've
just made cheating legal
that's gone on forever and you're
probably gonna have that no matter what
rules you put into so again we've got to
come to some sense of reality
of what this is all about this is about
the athletes and it's about their
education and about their future
it's not about the money and i know
everybody wants to make money and very
few make money in
in sports and in pros
the college is for most of them 98 of
them is the in the line right and if
they make some money out of it that's
fine but we want to try to again and
it's not about the amount of money it's
about when and where and why you know
that they they can get this done
and not affect everybody else i hate
that one or two players are going to get
money off of a team
and other players aren't
but
again
this is going to be hard to negotiate
but hopefully we can come up with
something yeah i guess you're right i
mean if somebody was going to give money
to an athletic program in general but
now they can give it to a kid
that's money you're right that's taken
out of
the volleyball budget or whatever it is
um all right coach one more thing when
you go home when you go home to alabama
um do people call you coach or people
call you senator right imagine i mean
senator's a demotion from coach for a
lot of people in alabama what do you
what do you go by
well there's no doubt about that they
still call me coach and matter of fact
the senators in the in the senate called
me coach
it's uh you know
i tell all of them you know i've earned
that 40 years of coaching and dealing
with all these kids and i really loved
it and enjoyed it it's special to be a
senator you know there's not 100 of us
but again i i like being recognized as a
coach that somebody hopefully did a
little bit good for college sports and a
lot of athletes over the last 40 years
coach tommy tuberville good to talk to
you thank you very much good luck with
this thank you chris
[Music]
this is dr marty mccary with your fox
news commentary coming up
as both sides prepare to barnstorm the
country in the closing months before the
midterm elections inflation remains the
buzz word for republicans i can't think
of many ways they haven't mismanaged
this economy senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell in his home state
kentucky this week slamming biden
administration policies while white
house economic adviser jared bernstein
continues to highlight indicators he
says do not point to recession despite
two quarters of contraction if you look
at the things that they look at payroll
employment growth extremely strong over
half a million jobs in july but the
surge in hiring may not last with a wide
variety of employers already announcing
job cuts this year from coinbase and
carvana to ford wayfare and netflix now
half of the companies in one new report
are planning layoffs so we have this new
survey out from pricewaterhousecooper
fox business correspondent madison
allworth they interviewed 700 executives
across u.s businesses and 52 percent are
either already having hiring freezes or
plan on having them in the near future
and 50
are planning to reduce overall head
count so we've been in a really strong
labor market for a long time the concern
though shows that companies are bracing
for potential downturn already prepping
their businesses and maybe already
making cuts we've seen a ton this summer
wow this seems like a pretty drastic
change from a year ago when employers
were really struggling to hire people
definitely so one thing that we've
looked at with employment numbers is you
know turnover rate or retention or
people just quitting if you can quit and
get a new job that's a sign that the
labor market is really strong so this
time last year six percent of workers
were quitting now we're just over four
percent so less people are leaving their
jobs which you might think oh that means
that they like their job but it also
might mean that they see that there's
not as many jobs out there for them to
jump to people were jumping for bonuses
jumping for higher pay
and that's kind of tightening now
i still see help wanted signs everywhere
it seems like it's everywhere so do
layoffs you know really depend on the
type of business or the size of the
company at this point yeah that's a
great question lisa definitely
the minimum wage worker or a lower pay
worker those are still really hard to
come by and that's why you're seeing
those sectors increase pay restaurants
increasing pay
hotel hospitality industries because
that is still incredibly hard talent to
find when you look at you know this pwc
survey those numbers that i ran through
that's definitely more of the corporate
world so there is that division between
types of labor
is part of the strategy to focus on
keeping existing workers happy
yeah so
i mean it's a lot less work and money if
you can keep people it costs money to
onboard people it costs money to get rid
of people or when people leave so
they're definitely doing what they can
to keep people on that's why i think
we've seen a lot of these long-standing
work from home policies because workers
want to stay home to go back to that pwc
survey they found 49 percent of
companies are encouraging employees who
left to rejoin so this is at a time when
they're doing hiring freezes and they're
they're looking for cuts and yet they
want people to rejoin because i think
there's a lot of value in an employee
that has been there or has been there in
the past
especially when companies maybe have
less margins to work with
even though some companies are allowing
full-time remote work
some are also attaching some pretty
significant strings to that is there a
growing push to keep better track of
productivity for remote staff yeah
there's a you know
necessity is a mother invention there's
a ton of companies now that track remote
workers this is things like how active
is your keyboard how often do you leave
your mouse how long does it take you to
craft an email and companies like bigger
firms are hiring these you know
companies are installing their software
to track their employees some of the
companies doing this barclays bank
united health group jp morgan
this has all been reported by the new
york times
because they want to know if their
remote workers are actually working but
i do think there's going to be an
interesting
evolution for companies we'll have to
see how it plays out because on the one
hand yes you are on the company's time
you've committed to eight hours but of
course i would imagine some of these
workers and i some of my friends say
if i get eight hours of work done in six
hours and i still have a solid end
product and i'm still delivering on
everything
what's the harm in that so
for now
employees have had the power because
companies are struggling for talent and
they're holding on to the workers as
long as they're getting the job done
even if it means that they're getting it
done in five hours and there's
technically three hours left on the
table um but we'll see if that's the
case going forward as we start to see
this shift
and it'll be interesting to see if it if
it does drive some workers away
knowing that they're
essentially being watched even if it's
just through you know keyboard strokes
definitely and i mean you already see
workers have been very selective with
their jobs but it's almost like a
competition thing if all the tech
companies for example have a hybrid
model or have some work from home
positions then those employees will
continue to take jobs like that but if
all companies get on the same place and
say we're going to track you if you're
home and or we also need you to come
into the office and if that's just the
new standard then people will have to
comply but we're seeing it like apple
for example
they're saying that after labor day they
want workers back in the office three
days a week apple employees really
pushing back on that there's actually a
petition that's going around arguing
that they want to stay home
apple's a huge powerful company you
should expect that most engineers people
want to work there but also apple has
the money to get the best engineers and
if that incredible engineer wants to
stay home are you really gonna force
them to come in you know a year ago they
would not have
now as things are changing maybe
we'll see
some unhappy workers
have become part of the so-called quiet
quitting movement um so maybe they're
sticking with their existing job but
they're limiting how much they're
willing to do for that job now that
seems like something that could easily
backfire yes it definitely seems like
something that could backfire i'm always
surprised when people are willing to
come out and say
you know i'm part of the quiet quitting
movement it obviously puts
some attention on you that probably is
not good when it comes to your employer
but it kind of gets to something you're
talking about earlier
of the work from home you get eight
hours of work done in five hours well if
you're in the office and you get your
eight hours of work done in five hours
you then go to your boss or you go to
your team and say what else can i take
on or is there another project i can
staff etc
but these quiet quitters they're just
doing you know maybe they're quote eight
hours or less
and that's it they're not going for the
next thing maybe they're filling more
time
with other you know other jobs some in
some cases
and it's about not one not going that
extra mile and in some cases
really just doing the bare minimum so
that you know you're not going to be
fired because job market is still really
tight you have that job security you
don't need to stress yourself so why do
it if you know your job is safe
will it be perceived or could it be
perceived as
um sort of a measure of changing
attitudes among you know younger members
of the workforce in particular
i mean
it's i'm sure it's a pandemic
ramification if you will among you know
various age groups um
could it be perceived as something
that's more among younger workers
especially because of all the upheaval
and and what's happened yeah i
definitely think so i mean any of the
reports i've seen on it and the stuff
that i've you know looked into when it
comes to quiet quitting it's always
young people that are quoted in the
articles um it's also because the idea
even the phrase has been spread through
social media channels that are
populated by young adults so i
definitely think it's there's that
divide there and and i think some people
would say like uh you know this is the
difference of the younger generation
versus the older like not wanting to
work hard knowing the value of work
um i do think you know there might that
might be part of the story but i do also
think to for the other side is um it
shows the
the change of value of work and also the
different working conditions today
versus say
40 years ago
when you have eight hours at your job
back when before the cell phone you did
your job and then you went home you
separated from your work you might get
calls to your house line et cetera but
now if you leave the office or even if
you leave your at-home desk you always
have your email on you you always have
your cell phone on you so i think there
is a justification there is a real
pushback of i don't want to give my
entire life to my job i don't think that
goes as far as quiet quitting but i do
think the younger generation quiet
quitters or not
do have this desire to separate from
work more because
that workforce grew up without any
separation at all
which is the other extreme definitely
not healthy as as which is another thing
that's been you know we've all been
learning in the pandemic i think
um you're out in the field a lot you've
spoken to so many different types of
businesses um you know the labor
shortage has been a big undercurrent now
all through the pandemic
what's what's the mood out there you
know on the street at businesses right
now i mean we're you know we're more
than two years since the start of this
um
how you know are they feeling optimistic
or does it seem like things are getting
better for businesses overall or it's
just as much of a struggle but in
different ways
yeah i think i would love to say that
you know things are turning up but i
think businesses continue to be pummeled
by
a multitude of factors that make it
really difficult to operate today labor
costs has been the a huge thing for
every business that i've spoken to
because to just get someone in the door
you have to offer
so much more than you did pre-pandemic
which also makes sense for the workers
when you go out and see the cost of
living whether it's housing or groceries
or gas
for example i was at a white castle the
other
the other week and so they've increased
the cost of labor and their products
cost more so they feel bad you know
they're charging the customer more but
they have to but doesn't mean that
they're taking home necessarily more
profit because all of the operating
costs have gone up so it's really a
vicious cycle because you feel like
labor and companies are still having a
difficult time getting that labor
retaining that labor um and it's not
like they can give us you know the
customers any benefit i've heard it from
the white castle i spoke to a coffee
shop owner her biggest thing is the
retention she comes in she'll train
someone they'll work for a week or two
and then they leave and we talked about
the beginning
there's a ton of time and money that's
sunk into that so you know kind of
making it full circle if it's true that
those
hiring freezes happen obviously not a
good thing but it would have an impact
on the labor market because that job
jumping has been something i've heard
from a lot of companies that has been a
struggle they it's difficult if you're
trying to run a business and you're not
confident that your employee will show
up because maybe they've left for
another job or maybe they're quiet
quitting or what have you so if those
hiring freezes if that you know quit
rate continues to go down there could be
more stability there so maybe there is a
bit
of good news on the horizon for
businesses but
it's definitely still a struggle out
there when it comes to hiring and
operating costs
fox businesses madison all worth a
pleasure to have you thanks so much
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
and in other news i'm gianna delosi if
you have a sweet tooth don't let the
crunchy granola types of people shame
you for your diet choices a new study
from tufts university has created the
food compass its nutrient profiling
system ranks how healthy foods are
looking at nutritional attributes linked
to major chronic diseases like obesity
diabetes cardiovascular problems and
cancer as well as the risk of under
nutrition they then give those options a
score it shows ice cream may be a better
option than your morning granola
researchers spent three years
investigating over 8 000 different types
of food and drink they gave them a score
between 0 and 100 with 100 being the
most healthy unsurprisingly whole foods
like fruits and vegetables ranked highly
on the list spinach even scored a
perfect 100
processed foods fast foods like burgers
with all the condiments much lower on
the scale but in between the two
extremes there were some surprising
findings chocolate ice cream with nuts
scored 35 points while a coconut and
chocolate granola bar received just 15
points frozen yogurt a treat touted as
the healthier alternative to ice cream
only scored 23. researchers note that
ice creams are dairy based and that
holds protein and nutrients versus
granola which is mostly refined starch
and sugar an egg omelet scored 51 points
cheerio scored 95 points corn flakes got
a measly 16 points researchers say
nutritional literacy is a little murky
for the general public once you go
beyond eat your veggies and avoid soda
and say you can apply the food compass
with a more regular consumption of food
and drinks scoring over 70 consuming
foods in the 31 to 69 range like ice
cream in moderation only and they say
options under 30 like those granola bars
should be minimized for the fox news
rundown i'm gianna delosi
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to fox
news podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
dr martin mccarran
what's on your mind the cdc director
just announced a widespread overhaul of
the agency while acknowledging
widespread failures and its handling of
the pandemic but the announcement does
not appear to be the result of
self-reflection and a true turnaround
instead they are trying to get ahead of
a general accountability office or gao
report coming out in the coming days
which is expected to be scathing the cdc
has lost the trust of the american
public
so it's not enough to say that change
will come the most telling indicator
that the cdc's mia culpa is not legit
is that it continues to uphold bad
policies
weeks ago based on cdc guidance the
military cut off 60 000 personnel for
not complying with its vaccine mandate
nearly all had natural immunity which
studies show is more protective than
vaccinated immunity alone
will the cdc call for their
reinstatement
if the cdc is correcting its misdeeds it
should start now it should stop pushing
boosters on teenagers and ask colleges
to remove their booster mandates it
should ask philadelphia school district
to remove the masks on students it
should tell government-funded head start
programs to stop requiring all children
ages 2 and up to wear masks
the cdc should also acknowledge that the
pfizer vaccine for babies and toddlers
was recommended by the agency even
though the clinical trial found no
statistical significant efficacy
and importantly
it should apologize for being complicit
in the human rights violation that was
the banning of americans to visit their
dying loved ones in the hospital for
most of the pandemic but instead of
addressing these issues the cdc is busy
at work on its publicity affairs
talk is cheap and promises are empty if
they're not accompanied by action
making any of the above policy changes
or public stances would signal that the
cdc is serious about doing better
what we need to see is the correction of
its mistakes not the promise of fewer
mistakes in the future
the cdc director michelle walinski said
in an internal video according to abc
news to be frank we are responsible for
some pretty dramatic
pretty public mistakes from testing to
data to communications
wilinsky said the agency is at a
watershed moment and promised reform
but while wallinsky's announcement
sounded like a major reform it appears
to be only addressing the periphery it
modifies the criteria for for internal
promotion of cdc staff
and speeds up the time for the agency to
review its own
flawed studies such as the maricopa mask
study which falsely concluded that
school mask mandates reduced covet
transmission
perhaps most telling the person the cdc
is bringing in to oversee its overhaul
is a long long-time government
bureaucrat mary wakefield a former
clinton appointee who has a
long-standing career in government
it would seem like a radical overhaul
would be led by someone with a business
record rather than a career bureaucrat
if the cdc is truly interested in an
overhaul it should start with correcting
its mistakes and making specific
apologies to americans
and children in particular
this is dr marty mccary professor at
johns hopkins university and a fox news
medical contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcast network
download listen and be inspired with
lauren green's lighthouse faith fox news
religion correspondent lauren green uses
her wealth of stories to take the
listener on a unique journey of
spiritual discovery subscribe and listen
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes